this is Frodo's burden to bear why pick
ranch time and this is probably gonna be
the most substantive complaint I've ever
registered as a nitpick rant because I'm
going to be talking about arguably the
main character of the film and to
complain fundamentally about the main
character the film goes beyond the scope
of what this series normally is normally
I pick on a specific scene a specific
incident that's single shot even
sometimes that just drives me crazy this
one it's a bit bigger and it reaches a
bit further but given how huge these
movies are and how many characters are
in it I feel like on the scale of the
film as a whole trilogy it's also
counted as an epic because it is also
pretty much my only real issue with
these movies cuz I love the Lord of the
Rings movies I love them when they came
out in theaters I loved them more when I
got the extended editions on DVD they
are awesome they are wonderful
however Frodo as a character makes these
films difficult for me to rewatch and
it's not one specific scene it is the
way the character plays out over the
course of the film and how he handles
various things at various points so it's
a culmination of a lot of things now
before I get too much into this I will
clarify I don't think the problem is
Elijah Wood I don't think there's
anything wrong with this performance I
think he does perfectly fine for how the
script was written and what was asked of
him by Peter Jackson I think he is
perfectly fine for what they asked him
to do
it's the the conceptual level of the
character that doesn't work and to say
it bluntly and then to get into it
Frodo is weak like really weak like too
weak for the narrative to work so
there's a there basically when you have
this kind of quest journey the the hero
needs to be over their head and he is
over his head he's in
over his head from the beginning however
generally these things need to go one of
two ways
either the hero starts out as being
shown or believed to be strong and
capable and able to do this but then you
beat them down and you really put them
through the wringer so that even the
strength that they showed you questioned
God will that be enough or you start
with someone who is in a position of
weakness who finds strength over the
course of the quest and with Frodo we
get neither he is shown to be weak and
unprepared right from the beginning and
that never ever changes and of course he
doesn't complete his quest not really he
gets it close enough that he that ends
up happening but he doesn't he doesn't
have that moment I'm not saying like
they should have changed the book to
make it that and I in general I'm not a
big it mostly just like a book person
but there is one scene from the
Fellowship of the Ring that the way that
they changed it
if they hadn't if they had left it as is
I might not have this complaint so in
the book in the Fellowship of the Ring
when Frodo is escaping the ring wraiths
the nazgûl and this is when they're
these trying to get to Rivendell the
flight from the for so he's fleeing from
them he gets on the other side of the
river in the book he stops and he faces
them down there on one side of the river
he's on the other and I forget the exact
line because honestly Tolkien wasn't
known for a particularly memory
memorable dialogue a lot of the time but
he says something like you know in the
name of you know some mythological thing
I defy you I stand against you and then
the the sort of stampede of water horses
comes down now he didn't summon that but
he also didn't know it was gonna happen
and he stood his ground and that is a
moment of strength that is a moment of
determination that is a moment of
there's more to this guy than we thought
that film Frodo doesn't have so for that
particularly scene
took it from him and they gave it to
Arwen so so that they could beef up her
part and I don't actually have a problem
with that but by taking that moment of
strength away from him so it's in the
film now instead it's her going you want
him to come and claim him and so it's
her moment of strength they took it away
from Frodo and they never gave him
another one to replace it think of all
the times right from the beginning that
Frodo is confronted with danger the
nazgûl near the Shire panicked get off
the road
and hides and am I saying that's an
unreasonable response but he's he's
panicked and scared right from the
beginning you know facing the Naza boat
later when he gets stabbed again
panicked and and that he seems he
doesn't have the confidence in himself
and he doesn't display the strength for
me that it makes any sense that they
gave him this quest
especially when Elrond gets the line the
Hobbit has shown remarkable resistance
to its influence meaning the ring go
back and look at those seeds look at
when they're hiding in the log from the
nazgûl not only was neo he is he in this
panicked state which again not
unjustified but he is tempted to put the
ring on right there you've got the
voices whispering his head he's kind of
and Sam stops him so right from the
beginning he's tempted to put it on is
he tempted as hard and as quickly as
somebody likes a Boromir no but that's
not resistance of this thing's influence
he's being nudged and manipulated by it
almost immediately he is so the wrong
person to even be attempting this quest
as he is shown in these films and it
never gets better he never has a moment
of his own strength every time he faces
a challenge he fails and he has to be
saved by someone else who's there so you
know I mentioned already with with and
Sam having to stop him when the NAS goes
there and then later in the two towers
you know he falls on the marshes and
Smeagol has to get him and then later on
that same movie he faces down an as ago
again and he just stands there he's
almost offering at the ring and Sam gets
him out of the way again
then of course Return of the King he
actually basically gives up gives up the
ghost completely and just loses control
of her but he never had control he never
comes across as being able so this isn't
like the ring chipping away at him this
is like the only reason that he doesn't
give in and give in to the ring in the
first film is cuz other people stopped
him and I understand you have to
establish that Sam has to be there that
he's that seems the only way he's gonna
make it but they oversold that and to
the point that I'm going why would
anyone assume Frodo has any possibility
of ever pulling this off this is one of
the weakest heroes in a fantastic movie
that I get to think about all and
because of that it's this one element
and another wise fantastic trilogy that
just drives me crazy
am i overanalyzing do you want to argue
that I'm wrong or did I just ruin these
films for you whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do if you like my stuff you can
support me on patreon plus you can
follow me on Twitter listen to podcasts
etc etc links for all that stuff is down
in the description so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]